what is up there reject nation we are
going to watch brooklyn 99
episode 7 today listen i've been hearing
social media messages there's been some
weird process for brooklyn nine-nine
every other day it's like a video gets
claimed and our video gets partially
blocked and then release that claim and
then a different one gets
this weird back and forth zigzag process
has been happening with the videos sorry
about that but right now only one is
currently claimed
after many different conversations and
disputes
so yeah but you know with that in mind
john did you know
that this video today is sponsored by
ridgewater oh my god my
favorite product ridge wallet yup i got
my water from here today too
guys red wallets are amazing you don't
even have to use the talking points
because these things are conversation
starters they save you space they got
money clip if you want it or a strap to
keep your stuff in line they got
tens of thousands of five star reviews
they're rfid blocking they come in
titanium aluminum
carbon fiber they even got designs with
pictures on them
that's insane you know that is what we
say in conversation without relying on
any talking points at all no talking
points i mean these are we clearly
actually using these are durable
enough these are law enforcement grade
wallets these are seriously
actual wallets that we use and i'm glad
rich keeps partnering up with us
because they help save us in times like
this when we're having issues or claims
like this
and it's nice to actually be sponsored
by a product that we genuinely use
daily uh so guys promo code in the
description box
reject nation save ten percent of your
order and get free shipping
yeah when you head to oh and then
ridge.com
reject nation that's our link i think
we've gotten too comfortable with this
because
now it's way off road and it's really
sloppy and also yeah full length watch
alongs for this or over on our patreon
page but
enjoy until it gets partially blocked
for a couple weeks
hey captain got a second it's captain
what did i say captain captain crunch
all right but to be fair captain crunch
was a war hero
and the primary male role model in my
house growing up so
that's sad jewelry store robbery down by
grand army plaza
i know who did it dustin whitman i put
him in rikers two years ago he just got
out and the crime scene matches his m.o
well let's see what kind of physical
evidence they turn up and then we can
talk a rest
actually hilarious story
so that is dustin whitman you
already arrested him with insufficient
evidence
by law we have 48 hours to find that
evidence so we have to let him go
you just started the clock oh cool
what's up with this emergency meeting
hello
big date tonight how do i look is this
why you were getting makeup tips from
the prostitute
in the holding zone so we have the next
48 hours to fix his mistake
what evidence did you have when you
arrested this guy some pretty ironclad
stuff
destined this cake cuddy been a while
mind if i ask you a few questions
well well well if it isn't joke peralta
that's it you're under arrest
[Laughter]
so cancel your plans we're here until
this is over damn it pearl tub
oh i know everyone's mad at peralta for
ruining their weekend
but that was it i was just demonstrating
for detective peralta what a fact
is always a lesson to be learned with
captain holt
i wish captain holt was real let's pull
two doubles you must be tired
i'm not tired why would you think i was
[Music]
tired
i ended up doing 25 minutes to sleep
chin ups on muscle memory alone
tired terry still gets after it that's
all i'm saying
hey gina can you order food for us at
the flatbush diner they make the best
pies in new york city the best pie in
the city is at crest
wrong boyle you're always blogging on
that foodie website which pie is better
yeah you see like better minor roses oh
uh you know i i haven't uh been
either uh place yet can i see you for a
second in the evidence lockup
charles i know what's going on you've
tried both pies
you know mine is better but you're
scared to tell rosa cause you're into
her
what it's not true
okay i i don't i don't i don't even like
food
what who's rosa you're the scared one
make some funny faces while i'm in there
i want to see if i can tell i didn't do
anything joke
you said the exact same thing last time
let's take a look here's you at your
trial
you in prison me meeting regis philbin
you still in prison you in prison you
imprison you in prison you get it
i got all the time in the world no you
actually have 48 hours
i know the law
nah
rise and shine detectives rise and shine
you slept in your office and you look
exactly the same
how what are you talking about my hair
is a mess
[Laughter]
just long enough for me to squeeze in a
quick workout
is that a nightgown that's my t-shirt
for my fat face
if at first you don't secede oh my god
try again
a lot of fat guy clothes have racist
overtones
i'm gonna go take another crack at
whitman you've been in there like five
times what are you gonna do
annoy him into talking ha ha
two three yeah
[Music]
didn't work pretty sure that's a torture
technique
hey captain will you please let everyone
else go i feel
bad that i ruined their weekend and i
can tell they're pissed at me charles
hasn't tried to high-five me all morning
yes i've taken the brunt of that
kitchen buds
i want to see more of them together good
thing i didn't reschedule my date for
tonight
we're never leaving here well maybe
that's a good thing you know
saved you from another lame internet
date with some lame guy named dirk or
mark
jiren he's not lame okay he works with a
friend of mine
he has a human name and i'm not telling
you what it is because you'll look him
up and make fun of him
i can't believe you think so little of
me that you would just
automatically assume is it luke mueller
all right you know what reschedule for
tonight i promise i will get us out of
here in time
fine i'm holding you to that where is he
taking you terrific let's get everyone
involved
dinner
dinner and a movie is the perfect first
date i think the perfect first date
doesn't feel like a first date at all
because you've known each other for a
few years maybe you even work together
and in one night you're laughing and
then all of a sudden it's like blamo
kissing for me cheap dinner watch
basketball
bone downs same as what i said
what are you doing holt said he didn't
have to come in here you don't come in
on days are supposed to work
i brought two pies one is from crest
and one's also from flatbush diner
charles could try them and tell us which
one is better how fun is that
so fun
i've got these overtime forms fetus
are you stifling a yawn oh no sir
i filled this out i just need you to
[Music]
permission you answer go home
6 out of 12. oh 12 why for the 12
components of food satisfaction
salty sweet sour bitter umami odor
sound sound come on charles try her
nasty pie
oh no oh wow that's the best play i ever
had
no no no what's this pie taste test it's
over i won
it's unacceptable if you want to know
which restaurant has better pies
you can't just have one guy try one pie
from each place
everybody needs oh god go
we're going to be here a while
you were at a parking meter two blocks
from the jewelry store an hour before
the robbery
you found out about my wife we both have
cards because we share a joint account
because we love each other you're
incapable of loving i'll prove it
i want my lawyer now
you have changed you used to go straight
to prison
can't ask him any more questions till we
find his lawyer and we can't find his
lawyer anywhere i'm sorry
oh
sound
oh another one for crust it's not
looking good
bring out the meringues i brought up you
that's so
nice you wanted something sir
look it's impossible to make you leave
but you do have to sleep
and that's an order can't sleep without
my whale songs
problems at home so you stay late at the
job but that only makes it worse
everything's great with my wife my
brother-in-law's in town and we do not
get along
he thinks i'm a weakling
let me get that for you oh my god
that's great
[Laughter]
please sergeant you're a grown man
now take your nap i see the lights on in
here i'm going to be very disappointed
in you
such a good bit
[Laughter]
he has an alibi geniuses he was at
torque it's a nightclub in cape may new
jersey
all night let's follow up on this alibi
yep you heard him skully hit the road no
you should have looked into this before
you made the arrest you go
oh captain i'm happy to go i love the
saltwater taffy down there scully loves
the saltwater taffy down oh
peralta's going go this is killing me
good die if it does come to that
i have but one wish before i go can i
please put your glasses on my penis i
just think that would be really funny
i'm not gonna say i'm not curious to see
what that looks like
i'm sorry about the whole pie blow-up
thing you're right the flatbush diner
pie
is awful thank you it's just i want rosa
to like me
oh most women don't really like it when
dudes
lie to them what except for me but
really this guy oh not
him yeah there's uh good news and
there's bad news the bad news is my
saltwater taffy place was closed and the
good news
whitman's alibi checked out security
footage from port oh
huh that's bad news right that is bad
news
sorry it's on me no detective scully
it's on peralta
no captain that's on santiago it's on me
it's still on
[Music]
[Laughter]
no go on my brother-in-law
is coming to have dinner with me on his
way to jfk your services will not be
necessary
because you need to go home and change
for your date what
i called handsome luke i explained the
weekend was entirely my fault partially
oh god well i guess we did just spend 48
hours locked in here together
come on solve it solve it
what locked in here together so we will
be filing a wrongful rest suit against
the nypd
he has a partner do me a favor take a
look at this picture and tell me what
you see
you and regis philbin awesome right
surprisingly down to earth guy and
definitely not the picture i meant to
show you
take a look at this that's the goatee
guy cellmate marcus cole
outside the jewelry store the two you
planned this together in prison
and you split the loot oh man i can't
believe he caught us
of course he did peralta is the best
[Laughter]
yes the flatbush diners pie is terrible
it's inedible so you were lying what the
hell boyle
crust isn't any better it's fancier but
it's all bells and whistles
they just need to be good oh my dude
best pie in new york city apple
from argos bakery founded 1910
recipe unchanged taste it
this is amazing the pie is so good i
hate it
high school [ __ ] sorry i said [ __ ]
i'm just really worked up
i love him so much hey uh
drinks on me who's in oh no i got the
date i got a chance come on
they just want to go home yeah but i
have to prove i'm not selfish so i don't
care what they want
[Laughter]
[Music]
so this is my desk dust jockey huh you
just sit here
eat your pickles wait for the criminals
to turn themselves in
derek i'm glad i found you there's been
a development in the russian mob case
oh yeah a killer has been spotted in the
warehouse down by the canal
so you want me first through the door
sir oh it's just you the swat team is on
another call
hey i'm not going to be able to make
dinner tonight hey no do you think do
you think
go terry yeah
i haven't downloaded you some whale
souls thank you sir
i'll never forget it
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't want them to end ever
damn that's good that was so fun
look i'm not gonna act like we don't see
the comments about twice a week
right it's clearly
there's a weird claim issue at times
so you know i feel like when the day
comes we could sort it out
one day we might be able to graduate to
twice a week it will happen
it is a lot of times the recovery shows
people want twice a week and this is one
that like
i would love to do twice a week
absolutely trust me i we see the
comments
um but you know it's kind of like
there's so much time and editing just to
make sure these can get up and then
there's like oh crap it's partially
blocked maybe a little bit ago and it's
always like
hey sometimes it's like two weeks last
time it was like a month so
yeah it's things like that of why it
makes it difficult too
and then also just the time for uh you
know having to
assemble this and stay on schedule for
everything else we covered with patreon
and the rest of youtube
that's why uh yeah it's like yeah so
watching this only takes 22 minutes
all the other stuff around it takes a
few hours
yeah managing everything else around it
during the week
yeah but uh yeah this show brings a lot
of joy and
uh yeah i think that could be the review
right there but let's talk about it
oh i can't wait to get my hair cut so
yes that was
awesome i love i love a good ticking
time clock
one of the old school lessons of writing
you gotta have a tick in time clock and
it always helps when there's a very
literal ticking time clock
and um yes succeeded
for in the first few minutes i was like
there's a couple it was it was the first
time i feel like
with experiencing so far only a few
episodes in of
some of these jokes are not quite really
hitting but it just
eventually started getting so
so warm again and so heartfelt and so uh
i love the pulse and how like i've
talked about the editing in the last
episode and i really feel like the
editing on this one too
they really knew how to progress this is
an easy situation where you could have
just kept the editing at this one
thing of like it's supposed to be
ticking time clock 48 hours
40 hours 30 hours but they knew how to
keep ramping up the
the energy and sort of the intensity
without letting the intensity distract
from the fun comedy you know what i mean
because it could easily get caught up
in the clock so much what i often notice
with this show
is what could go wrong about what
they're doing
and how they're not doing that and
that's why it's working so
well and yeah to me this was just a
really cool one because i i did find
myself like oh and i really hope they
solve this
very yeah there's got to be something i
keep
you keep waiting for that moment of oh
my god i've got it and there's like a
few fake outs about that
and i keep waiting for that moment and
then they had the picture with the guy
that go tea i was like
maybe the guy's behind the guy with the
goat yeah i just kept waiting for it so
i love how that really gets you uh
wrapped up in it and it also really
seemed to hone in on teasing uh bringing
it back to
it seems like they're really letting
that build of
santiago and peralta you know oh yeah i
don't know if they get together in the
show
but it seems like the seeds are being
planted slowly but surely
yeah ever since the first episode but
even like this one in particular
uh was very much doing that without
doing it like i love how they
they end it with i got you your date and
there's nothing of like oh no i want to
go to the date with you but i'm gonna
you want to go on the date with this
like there's nothing it's not like boyle
and rosa where boyle's
evidently apparently into uh rosa
it's like you get the sense that peralta
and santiago are probably into each
other but they don't know it
yeah no i don't want to admit it yeah i
was thinking about that too because yeah
that scene they have together
in the the i forget they're in like a
little side office together
like that felt like something was like
oh yeah they have like a really easy
going
uh rapport together you know it seems
like a very natural fit where yeah you
wouldn't necessarily
uh in their shoes think you know that a
romance could you know be down the line
but you know for us
as the audience you know it's it's it's
cool because it's like it's it's nice to
see that those characters can
just hang and have like a tender moment
that's just kind of friendly but also
then it opens up
yeah those possibilities for the future
and in a yeah in a way that contrasts
from
the rosa and charles story and i loved
what they did with that this episode too
the whole like pie competition and
and you know it's like boyle is often
the brunt of many many jokes and so to
watch him have to
flounder in this awkward position
between rosa and gina and then finally
at the end of the episode come in
and and stop the argument by bringing
the best pie
himself you know is is a bit of a
classic comedy bit but i thought it
played really
charmingly here and and two like just
some of the smaller character bits uh uh
what's his name hitchcock with salt
water taffy and all that
yes no that was scully scully scully is
the one yeah yeah yeah
uh you know those little bits and uh and
hey we even got kid cudi
uh yeah oh that was kid cuddy that's
kick cutting damn
yeah why didn't i put that together yeah
yeah i was like wow oh yeah
right at the top i didn't quite hear it
yeah yeah yeah you know
those noise canceling headphones but uh
i thought he was like he didn't get like
the most
comedy to do but you know he fit right
in in this environment
i constantly fail to recognize artists
it's okay singers and stuff that's what
i'm here for
he's a millionaire right yeah yeah and
he's in need for
speech so so he's also an actor and
doesn't just rely on his singing skills
yeah on his on his musical career in
order to get roles okay that makes sense
yeah it was fun he was charming yeah and
um
uh oh the bit that i really love
the bit with the older brother it sounds
oh yeah it's so small
in here but just like the the
visual comedy of it was so well done
yeah like you were scared of your older
brother
and the way they do the reveal of that
it just pulls back and it's just a [ __ ]
taller bigger guy it was just so that
was hilarious
was that michelle i swear that's the
actor who was in dodgeball as michelle
maybe i feel better honestly i remember
the joke better of michelle than i do
okay of uh i don't think that's him
we'll comment maybe you're probably
right you're usually better at that than
i am
um yeah that what that's that's a really
solid point and
i uh i loved like how small it was
but they did such a good job at
alluding that there's something more
going on because like the physical
comedy they do with terry is really
funny
yeah like how he's just it's really it's
impressive like how he's able to just
stay there and not look like he's
holding on like i would try to do
taking if i were to do that bit you'd
have to like you know green screen out
some wires
maybe they did but i can also believe
that he just no i'll just stay here
get up for a minute we're set up all
right and roll it yeah it's a really
it's a really funny bit and the the way
they handle the physical comedy of him
is great and terry crews in this show i
think is awesome because
he has he's like in the expendables and
[ __ ] like he has
this build this look of where he could
just play tough guy
or something but i've seen him in so
many other things where he's
mainly honest in on his comedy skills
and for a guy with that like level of
physique i know he's had some of his own
controversial problems with certain
statements he's made or done
in real life i don't really follow it
like but anyway that's beside the point
in terms of here
he's really uh it's really cool to see
how
it is it's such a natural side of his
personality it doesn't look like they're
like we're trying to make tough-looking
guy be funny you know it's it's this
seems like the real authentic game and
he just happens to be massive
yeah i keep getting this impression and
maybe it's just because of what everyone
said about like they wanted him so bad
they named the character actor
but i i really wonder if so much of the
actual terry character in this show is
just based off of real terry cruzisms
i met him once really what was that like
it was very brief it was before brooklyn
9-9 i think i
think he was like uh when i used to cook
hot dogs
oh did he come in for a dog he walked he
walked past
he was walking with a friend and i just
said hey man i really love your work
and he's like oh thank you man it means
a lot and i just walked away dude
he probably remembers that yeah then he
did 500 sit-ups
on the spot yeah thanks for the
compliment man let me show off for you
yeah i gotta get back to work dude
uh yeah that was that was good this is a
really
really uh really awesome episode they
utilized it well
yeah and it's it's interesting how they
play with certain motifs to keep it
like damn hey yeah it's been show's been
going on for so long
i'm sure there's a couple of seasons
here or there that falter
but i'm already surprised by how it
seems like they keep
trying to make it fresh every time i'm
like really like eight episodes
yeah why are you guys working so hard
that's just quality tv
right there usually they find a formula
and it just stick to it right away for
like the first season and this one i'm
like yeah
they mix it up like every episode yeah
yeah which i think especially
if for a la procedural comedy i think is
actually
important because there are so many
a lot of procedurals already that follow
if exact format
and i feel like part of the fun of this
is being able to at least mix it up a
little bit in the inroads you get to
what the mystery is how it forms how we
solve it
and i i appreciate it's weird i don't
want to keep drawing this comparison but
in a way
it makes me think of psych because that
show
again every episode has some kind of
murder or a case but the
inroads to it are not always just the
standard like
police in road you know they're often
character-driven
inroads to the stories and you know
crime scenarios and i feel like
this show does a version of that as well
you know yeah or it's not always the
same
setup and then oh what are they gonna
plug into it you know
yeah they have a good psychological take
on their characters
yeah and it seems character driven in a
way
no they really know their characters uh
very well like the littlest lines allude
to how well they know their characters
of like right down to peralta's line of
like no i need to buy everyone drinks to
show them how that
i'm not selfish so i don't care what
they're doing it's like
that's such a honest thing that
so many people do yeah like i'm trying
to be giving
to show you what i'm giving but i'm kind
of approaching this in a selfish way
like that doing it only with my
own thought of how to do it in mind
because i want to make you feel good to
alleviate me
not really for you uh and so i i love
uh i love those like attention to
details like the way they handle the
writing and
i'm sure andy sandberg occasionally
improvises but the way they handle the
writing of
uh his because andy sanberg's good at
playing like doofus narcissist
yeah yeah yeah absolutely and i i really
uh i really think like it's just so well
molded for his character usually he's
like
slacker and stuff that we see even like
palm springs yeah you know
yeah like he said it's just like a
slacker kind of guy
and then here's i love his character
because he's
genuinely good at his job um he's just a
bit of a rascal
yeah yeah yeah it's like this it's like
a weird spin on like
you know like the the hard difficult to
work with detective who plays by his own
rules but he is good at his job
yeah but he generally gets along with
everybody
but they instead of having like the grim
edge of that character who's like a
loner-esque
he's a needy emotional yeah
he really needs the team around him yeah
he's uh
yeah he needs people and needs
validation and needs to be plugged in
he's like the lone wolf who truly
shouldn't do it alone you can't do it
alone and that's part of the
the point yeah all right guys well
brooklyn nine-nine awesome episode leave
your thoughts down below thank you to
rich
for sponsoring this video get yourself a
ridge wallet
and last but not least
aaron myers you're new to our patreon
page
but you know what i have a good feeling
about you
you know why aaron because
a stands for
apples because you are at the beginning
of this like adam and eve
ooh make the next a little better john a
is for avuncular because
you probably have a fun energy
similar to that of someone's fun uncle
i am watch this r is for
ridge wallet because you should get a
ridge wallet rejection code
ridge.com reject
stands for optometry which
you should study it's a noble profession
and you need a job and
n stands for
necronomicon because
let's face it you seem like the kind of
guy who's likely to
have a necronomicon on here i found this
book in my own skin
please don't ask for a refund aaron i
really appreciate
you being here didn't mean to insinuate
anything
we have to shout out aaron myers before
i feel like maybe he's got like a
deadpool uh
yeah icon we need to do the same shadow
do we i don't think so
let's confirm let's confirm it oh this
is a meta shout out
this is gonna be the shout out within
the shout out oh wait no i remember now
aaron was the guy who said
make fun of me however you want oh yeah
oh so then your shout out
your shoutout's fine though yeah on you
yeah
[Music]